-I always love when you come on.
Thank you so much for coming
back to the show, bud.
-They just told me
I've been here nine times.
-Isn't that crazy?
-That's crazy right there.
-I want you to be here
100 times.
-Let's go.
-I can't get enough of you, bud.
I have something here that I
don't think I've ever thought
I'd see in my lifetime,
and I've been a fan of yours
for a long time.
You are on a Cheerios box.
[ Laughter ]
Look at that.
That's what I'm talking about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I made it!
-Wow, Honey Nut Cheerios.
If you ever told me
as a kid like,
"Ice-T is going to be
on a cereal box --"
-Impossible.
You could put a gun to my head
and said -- I'd be like, "No.
No way is that going to
ever happen."
And I'd be shot
because it happened.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you a fan or did they reach
out? How did it happen?
-They reached out,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm a little older now,
and they wanted
somebody to represent
heart health.
And, you know, it's been
a changing of the guards, Jimmy.
You know, the people
that were scared of us
in hip-hop are gone now.
So you go to the CEOs
of these big companies,
they're like 45-year-old guys,
you know, or women,
and they're just like,
"I love you."
I mean, that's how we made it
into the Super Bowl.
You know, everybody
who was at the Super Bowl
were the "bad guys," you know?
50 and em all of --
Snoop and everybody.
So the guards have changed,
and now the people in power
love hip-hop,
and I'm on a Cheerios box.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think it's great.
Isn't that wild?
That's so good.
I think It's an honor.
It actually also inspired
something
called the Ice-T challenge.
This is a thing
that you did not start.
Your fans started this.
-They started it.
What they would do is
they'd go in the stores
and they'd flip the box around
to where they said,
"Ice, you should have been
on the front of the box."
And all over the country, people
are flipping these boxes around.
It's real crazy.
-Look at this.
This is actually happening
in grocery stores.
People just going in,
they go, "No."
[ Cheers and applause ]
I like that challenge.
-It's cool, it's cool.
You know, it's fun.
Nobody gets hurt.
-I'm going to do it
this weekend.
-Yeah.
-I think it's fun.
I think it's good.
I'll get the kids doing it too.
You know, I follow you
on the socials.
You're a great follow.
I've said this before.
I do love following you.
But this thing caught my eye the
other day, and I was concerned.
I go, "Oh, my gosh."
And it got national attention.
This is from you, @finallevel.
It says,
"I was robbed at a gas station
in New Jersey last night.
After my hand stopped trembling,
I managed to call the cops.
They were quick to respond
and calm me down.
My money is gone.
The police asked me
if I knew who did it,
and I said,
'Yes. It was pump number nine.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's a good joke.
-That joke got a million likes.
I never got a million likes on
Twitter before.
I got to tell the truth.
My buddy Caz,
from Rollin' Sixties
hit me with that joke,
and I kind of rewrote it
and I put I was in New Jersey
and all that kind of stuff.
So, I kind of plagiarized
his joke.
He gets some credit, too.
-Yeah, Caz, yeah,
you get a little --
-Yeah, Caz hooked it up.
-Yeah, he hooked up.
-But it was on the news.
I'm watching,
you know, channel -- CNN.
"Ice-T gets robbed."
People like negative stuff.
I think what caught everyone's
attention was the fact,
"Ooh, something bad happened."
You know, people like stuff
that happens bad to people.
If it said Ice-T won something,
that something great happened,
they'd scroll right by.
"He got robbed! What happened?"
You know what I'm saying?
And then I got them in the end
with pump nine,
you know I'm saying?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You got them with the joke.
Pump nine -- I loved it.
You also do a thing,
a recurring thing on Twitter,
a thing called Ice Cold Facts.
-Yeah.
-And these are inspirational
sometimes, motivational tweets
from you, pieces of advice
from you.
-Things I've heard or things I
made up, just things that people
need to know
that are actually facts.
-I thought that we could go
through a few of your tweets
and you can tell us
a little more about
your thoughts behind them.
-Let's go.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
I like that.
That's pretty good too.
"Let's go" is even good.
-That's a fact.
We're about to go.
-Let's go.
We're about to go. That's right.
Alright, ice cold fact.
"At some point you're going to
realize that
if you don't go get it,
it's not going to get got."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That is --
Dude, that's good.
-I mean, you just can't sit on
the -- You can't say,
"I'm gonna go to gym"
and just sit on the couch.
It's not like you're
just automatically
going to get in shape.
You've got to go.
And anything you want, no one --
I'll back that up with no one
wakes up in the morning
with your dream.
Whatever your dream is,
it's yours.
So if you want it to happen,
you have to make it happen
personally.
Don't expect it to happen
because someone else
is going to care about
what you want.
-Yeah. I love that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love that.
Ice cold fact.
-Uh-oh.
-"A lie will get around
the world twice
before the truth can get
its pants on."
[ Laughter ]
-Kind of going back to
what I'm saying.
People love the lies,
they love the drama,
so drama spreads really,
really fast, you know?
Something that's true
and positive, unfortunately,
humans don't connect to that.
I mean, that's just a case study
in our human nature.
-Yeah. And then -- Yeah.
But I like it can go
around the world before
the truth can get its pants on.
-Yeah, before you can even get
up. What they lying about?
-Yeah, what's that about?
-What they lying about?
Let me tell them. It's too late.
-I'll do this last one.
[ Laughter ]
I want to do this last one.
Ice cold fact.
"If you follow me on
Twitter or Instagram,
your life will improve."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I agree.
I totally agree as a follower.
I love seeing your stuff.
It always makes me laugh
and it always makes me think.
-I mean, there's nothing to be
said about that.
That's just an ice cold fact.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
I want to talk about
"Law & Order: SVU."
-Let's go.
-You're about to wrap up
season 23.
Is that possible?
-Right now, we are filming
the final episode of season 23.
We got the record at 21,
and now I'm hoping we go to
like season 29 or something.
I mean, this year we had some
of the best ratings ever.
It's just -- I'm lucky to be
on board that ship.
-Can you tell us
how the season ends?
-I don't die.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, alright,
well, that's good.
Do you worry about that?
-Yeah.
Yeah, when you're on a show
this long, like, you know,
I read the script and I get
shot, I'm like, "I'm shot."
And I start "uh, uh, uh, uh,
oh, oh, oh, right there."
[ Both exhale ]
"I'm alive."
[ Laughter ]
I got shot on page 20.
43, I'm breathing.
[ Laughter ]
Yes!
-"I love you, Dick Wolf."
-I'm like, "Yo, let me know
something, man."
-Congrats on another
great season.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Ice-T in
"Law & Order: SVU."
Take a look at this.
-It'll be worth it.
Juana Ramirez is the soul
of this neighborhood.
-If anything is going on,
she'll know about it.
-Okay, I'm gonna wait out here.
Nobody likes a bakery
full of cops.
Get me a coffee and some chisme.
-Come on, Ice-T, everybody.
Come on, you know how to do it.
"Law & Order: SVU" returns
with new episodes April 28th.
We're playing "Settles It"
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.